Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es wird allerhöchste Zeit, mal wieder auf die europäischen Top-Ligen zu gucken. Herzlich willkommen zur Rasenfunk Ligatour. Heute mit Spanien, Frankreich, Italien und wen hab ich denn vergessen? Mensch, das geht ja ganz grandios. Los, ich krieg nicht mal die vier Ligen zusammen, über die wir sprechen wollen, aber ihr habt ihn schon gehört. David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 390 ist mal wieder mit dabei und er hat mich gerettet, also England war die vierte Liga. Hallo David und ebenfalls mit dabei sind Christian Bernhard für die Serie A, Fabian Pakulat für die Spanische La Liga und Hendrik Buchheister für die Premier League. Ihr seht schon, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, die größte Herausforderung heute wird so halbwegs ein bisschen in der Kurzpasszeit noch zu bleiben, deswegen gar keine große Begrüßungsorgie, sondern wir legen direkt los. Wir gucken als Allererstes in die Spanische Liga, auf La Liga. Da haben wir in der letzten Ligatur, die ziemlich genau einen Monat her ist, haben wir da, Fabian, viel über Barca sprechen müssen eigentlich schon, ein bisschen über Real. Alles andere ging dann schon so ein bisschen unter. Deswegen bin ich gespannt, über was würdest du denn gerne sprechen? Was hat sich denn jetzt nach fünf gespielten Spieltagen getan?
Es gab ja auch ein spektakuläres 1 zu 2 gegen die Young Boys aus Bern in der Champions League unter der Woche. Und in der letzten Folge der Ligatur hat auch schon Uli Hebel sich ähnlich kritisch geäußert gegenüber Solskjaer. Wir werden das weiter verfolgen wollen. Es ist aber nicht zu viel Zeit nur auf United zu verlieren. Es gibt ja auch noch andere Mannschaften. Aktuell sind ja ebenfalls mit 13 Punkten vorne Chelsea und Liverpool. Aber Paul, wie gefallen dir denn die bisherigen Auftritte dieser beiden Mannschaften?
Ja, sehr gut, muss man sagen. Das ist jetzt keine wahnsinnig steile These. Also beide fünf Spiele noch ohne Niederlage. Bei Chelsea war es erwartet worden. Logischerweise Champions-League-Sieger mit Thomas Tuchel, ein Trainer, der wirklich auf das Optimus dieser Mannschaft herausholt und sich mit Romelu Lukaku noch mal verstärkt hat. Und auch so eine offene Flanke geschlossen hat, damit man jetzt auch einen Mittelstürmer hat, der auch Tore schießt. War ja bei Chelsea nicht immer so in der vergangenen Saison. Von daher, dass Chelsea da oben so weitgehend, oder mit ziemlich weiter Weste oben steht, das war zu erwarten gewesen. Bei Liverpool ist es ein bisschen überraschend, weil sich schon viele Leute gefragt haben nach der letzten Saison, die für Liverpool-Standards ziemlich enttäuschend war. Und nachdem man jetzt auch nicht groß eingekauft hat im Sommer, also Konati war der einzige Transfer, war so ein bisschen die Erwartung und die Befürchtung, dass das Liverpool abfällt, halt eben in der Chelsea, Man Utd, Man City. Und das ist bisher nicht zu sehen. Also Liverpool und Klopp hat seinen Mojo zurück, wie man jetzt hier mehrfach schon gelesen hat nach den letzten Spielen. Dazu trägt natürlich Beiderst und Virgil van Dijk wieder da, als der einfach der Schlüsselspieler in dieser Mannschaft ist. Dazu trägt die Rückkehr des Publikums, glaube ich, bei. Das ist natürlich ein Klischee, wenn man sagt, Liverpool ist besonders auf die Fans und auf Anfield und so weiter angewiesen. Und ich kann es auch nicht mehr hören, aber ich glaube, im Endeffekt kommt man um diesen Faktor einfach nicht drum rum. Und Liverpool kann jetzt ein bisschen, anders als in der letzten Saison, kann jetzt auch ein bisschen rotieren. Also in der Champions-Sequence war er gegen Milan, saß dann Van Dijk zum Beispiel mal draußen. Das war unproblematisch. Jetzt in der Liga zuletzt gegen Crystal Palace musste dann James Milner plötzlich rechts auf der rechten Abwehrseite spielen. Und James Milner ist ja ohnehin jemand, der so jegliche Rationalität, so ein bisschen entgegen jeglicher Rationalität ja immer noch da ist und immer noch seine Leistung bringt. Eigentlich egal auf welcher Position. Konade hat zum ersten Mal gespielt in der Premier League. Giorgi Giotta ist vorne sehr, sehr wichtig. Firmino ist noch so ein bisschen hinten dran. Also Liverpool kann jetzt auch mal so ein bisschen rotieren, was der Mannschaft sicher zugutekommt. Und von daher ist man jetzt mit 13 Punkten Punkt und auch Torgleich mit Chelsea. Also gleiche Anzahl an Toren geschossen. Zwölf gleiche Anzahl an Gegentoren. Chelsea liegt nur aufgrund der alphabetischen Reihenfolge. Also C, V, L auf Tabellenplatz 1. Ich weiß nicht, ob das am letzten Spiel auch so entschieden werden würde. Aber von daher, genau, die Mannschaften gleich auf. Beide gut anzuschauen. Und wie gesagt, bei Chelsea war es so ein bisschen erwartet worden. Bei Liverpool ist es eher überraschend. Und haben ja auch schon gegeneinander gespielt. Bei diesem durchaus spektakulären 1-1, wo Chelsea ja zu Zehnt dieses Remis verteidigt hat vor der Länderspielpause. Bei Liverpool muss man mal schauen, wenn jetzt die großen Gegner kommen. Also Anfang Oktober geht es gegen Man City. Dann kommt oder geht es gegen Man United. Also mal schauen, ob sie dann immer noch tatsächlich in Schlagdistance zur Tabellenspitze oder sogar in der Tabellenspitze stehen. Aber bislang muss man sagen, macht Liverpool das sehr, sehr gut. Und wie gesagt, aus Sicht vieler beobachter auch überraschend gut.
Ja, da waren wir auch durchaus etwas zurückhaltender in der letzten Sendung. Ist ja auch schön zu sehen, wenn man da positiv überrascht wird. Was ich auffällig finde mit Blick auf die Tabelle, ist, dass wir gleich drei Mannschaften haben, die erst ein Gegentor in fünf Liga-Spielen kassiert haben, nämlich Chelsea, Liverpool und Manchester City. Bei City fällt dann so ein bisschen das 6 zu 3 gegen Rasenball-Sport Leipzig raus. Wir haben hier in der Bundesliga ja viele Diskussionen, wenn Bayern mal wieder Bochum mit 7 zu 0 abfertigt, ob das nicht alles langweilig sei. Ist das jetzt ein Zufall? Also, dass die eine gute Verteidigung haben, das ist mir natürlich schon klar, aber ich finde, ein Gegentreffer nach fünf Spielen ist halt wirklich krass, wenn das mehrere Mannschaften schaffen. Ist das jetzt eben nur dem Spielplan geschuldet, oder würdest du sagen, man sieht halt schon einen Trend, dass die Schere der Big Six zu den anderen Vereinen auseinandergeht?
Naja, also Big Six, das muss man ja auch wieder so ein bisschen einschränken, weil die gibt es ja praktisch nicht mehr. Also Arsenal Spurs sind ja schon ein gutes Stück abgefallen, jetzt ja auch nicht erst in dieser Saison. Es gibt schon immer mal wieder die Diskussion, wenn Manchester City dann 5-0 gegen Norwich gewinnt oder in der Vorsaison 7-0 gegen Watford. Also das gibt es dann schon auch, dass das Gefälle zwischen den Top-Teams und den kleineren Teams der Premier League wirklich zu hoch ist. Was natürlich die Premier League auszeichnet im Vergleich zur Bundesliga, ist, dass du nicht nur einen Verein hast, der in der Lage ist, andere Vereine mal eben mit 4, 5, 6 Gegentoren abzufertigen, sondern im Zweifel halt mehrere Vereine. Und dass du halt immer noch nicht nur einen Verein hast, der Meister werden kann und dann vielleicht so 1, 2 Konkurrenten, sondern du hast halt 3, 4 Vereine. Und ich glaube, dass diese Konstellation, und wo die Premier League auch sehr, sehr stolz drauf ist, diese hohe Competitiveness, dass das oft so ein bisschen darüber hinwegtäuscht, dass es natürlich doch ein klares Leistungsgefälle in der Premier League gibt.
Und gibt es da abschließend eine Mannschaft, wo du sagst, die fällt da raus? Also, wen gibt es so in der Premier League, wenn du jetzt sagst, du darfst jetzt noch über ein Team reden, dann schneide ich mit dir das Mikrokabel durch. Und es soll vielleicht keiner von den bekannten Namen sein oder von den Namen, die einen sofort einfallen. Gibt es da eine Mannschaft, die dir sofort in den Sinn kommt?
Ich hätte natürlich Brighton genannt, aber die haben wir schon besprochen. Von daher will ich gerne auf Aston Villa hinweisen, die ich extrem interessant finde. Also erstens, weil es ein großer Club ist mit einem großen Umfeld, großer Tradition, Wahnsinnsstadion auch. Und die ja aber im Sommer bekanntermaßen den besten Spieler verloren haben, Jack Grealish, für 100 Millionen Pfund. Und das sind ja ungefähr 118 Millionen Euro an Manchester City. Wo natürlich die Befürchtung groß war, ob jetzt Aston Villa auseinanderfällt. Und die haben aber meiner Meinung nach wahnsinnig gut eingekauft, dieses Geld wahnsinnig gut investiert. Leon Bailey aus Leverkusen, Danny Ings, ein klassischer Torjäger von Southampton. Und Emiliano Buendia von Norwich, der Abstand besten Spieler der 2. Liga in der vergangenen Saison. Und Aston Villa ist 10. Also die spielen jetzt auch noch nicht die Sterne vom Himmel. Aber ich finde es trotzdem interessant zu beobachten, wie sich dieser Verein weiterentwickelt. Leon Bailey hat jetzt, gerade am Wochenende gegen Everton, einen ziemlich beeindruckenden Einsatz hingelegt, das eingewechselt wurde. Nach einer Stunde hat ein Eigentor per Ecke mehr oder weniger provoziert, hat ein Tor selbst geschossen, und ist dann nach 20 Minuten verletzt wieder ausgewechselt worden. Also das ist auch wirklich sehr, sehr effizient, dieser Kurz-Einsatz gewesen. Und ich finde, Aston Villa ist ein Verein, den man auf jeden Fall im Blick behalten sollte, eben wegen des Gülisch-Abgangs, aber auch eben der Lösung, die sie dann gefunden haben, um dieses Geld zu reinvestieren.
Henrik, wie schätzt du den Western United ein? Die haben in den letzten Jahren, auch, glaube ich, einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht. Ich sage es deswegen auch, weil ein Freund von mir ist Tschechien, da spielen, glaube ich, jetzt zwei, drei tschechische Nationalspieler. Und mit Pablo Fornals haben sie auch einen, der beim FC Malaga mal gespielt hat, der da, glaube ich, auch im Moment ziemlich an Feier ist. Wie schätzt du die Hammers ein?
Ja, total interessanter Verein. Und die Tschechen, die du angesprochen hast, also Soufal und Suchek, waren in der letzten Saison tatsächlich die entscheidenden Spieler. Zusammen dann mit Trainer David Mois, der sich so ein bisschen rehabilitiert hat, weil er nach seinem gescheiterten Engagement bei Man United als Witzfigur, muss man tatsächlich sagen, in England angesehen wurde. Der aber tatsächlich West Ham stabilisiert hat und ja auch zu Recht in die Europa League geführt hat. Das Problem ist jetzt, dass einer der wichtigsten Spieler der letzten Saison war, ja auch Jess Lingard, der jetzt zurück zu Manchester United gegangen ist und jetzt auch direkt gegen West Ham das Siegtor geschossen hat passenderweise. Aber ich glaube, die Gefahr, dass die jetzt wirklich abfallen und irgendwie Richtung Abstiegskampf oder so, wo sie in den vergangenen Jahren oft waren, wieder rutschen, die sehe ich nicht. Also die sind jetzt Achter und da glaube ich, da wird sich West Ham auch einpennen. Und das ist dann auch für West Ham verhältnisvoll.
Sehr gut. Haben wir schon deinen TV-Tipp, hatten wir den schon erwähnt? Oder wen würdest du empfehlen, bei welcher Mannschaft sollte man einschalten bei der Premier League?
Ich dachte, das wäre schon die Frage nach den kleineren Clues. Das wäre schon der TV-Tipp gewesen. Nein, das ist total in Ordnung. Man kann sich natürlich Brandford immer anschauen. Die sind spannend. Aufgestiegen mit einem interessanten Pressing-Stil. Wenn sie den Ball haben, auch sehr ansehnlich nach vorne. Spielend mit einem absoluten Ausnahmestürmer. Ivan Tony, Torschützenkönig der Champions-Chip in der vergangenen Saison. Wahnsinnig sicherer Elfmeterschützer. Das hat er jetzt auch bewiesen. Im letzten Spiel gegen die Wolves. Brandford 5 Spiele, erst eins verloren. Die werden die Saison wahrscheinlich die Rolle einnehmen von Leeds United in der letzten Saison. Der interessante Aufsteiger, der sich wahrscheinlich relativ komfortabel in der Liga halten wird.
Von denen hat ja auch schon Uli Hebel in der letzten Folge auch schon vorgeschwammt. Also da gebt ihr euch die Hand.
Genau, ist ja auch der Verein, der auf dieses Moneyball-Prinzip setzt. Das muss man wahrscheinlich bei Brandford auch immer einmal erwähnt haben. Auf diesen ganz speziell datenbasierten Scouting-Ansatz. Und das klappt bislang gut. Haben auch einen deutschen Spieler, Italiener, U21-Europameister, der dort Stammspieler ist im defensiven Mittelfeld. Also, die kann man sich auf jeden Fall anschauen. Ist ein interessanter Verein. Wenn wir jetzt schon über die deutschen Connections sprechen, möchte ich mal ganz kurz Norwich erwähnen, Norwich City. Kann man sich auch immer anschauen. Da fallen auch immer viele Tore, allerdings meistens für den Gegner. Also, Norwich fünf Spiele, fünf Niederlagen, Kawellenletzter. Das besteht die große Gefahr, dass sie da auch bleiben.
14 Gegentreffer bisher. Hendrik, ganz herzlichen Dank an dich. Ganz herzlichen Dank an euch alle. In Abwesenheit danke ich David Frogier de Ponlevoy et un gungung vn auf Twitter. Ich werde natürlich alle Twitter-Handles und Namen wie immer in die Show-Notes packen. Da könnt ihr den Gästen hier folgen. Und danke dann sehr herzlich in Reihenfolge des Erscheinens. Fabian Pakulat werde ich natürlich auch verlinken. Danke dir, Fabian, dass du mit dabei warst. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Ich freue mich schon. Dann Christian Bernhard. Danke dir, Christian, für deine Zeit. Und zuletzt natürlich Hendrik Buchheister. Vielen Dank, dass du uns den Blick auf die Insel erleichtert hast. Danke dir, Hendrik. Und euch lieben Hörern und Hörern, danke fürs Zuhören. Lasst gerne Feedback da im Forum und in den sozialen Netzwerken, wie euch jetzt diese Form der Ligatur gefallen hat. Länge ist ein bisschen ein Problem, aber andererseits haben wir auch viel erfahren. Ich bin gespannt, wie ihr das alles findet. Und dann schauen wir einfach, wie wir das weitermachen im Rasenfunk. In diesem Sinne, wir sind allein Hörerinnen und Hörer finanziert. Unterstützt uns gerne, rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und dann hören wir uns in der nächsten Woche wieder. Bis dahin, macht's gut.